okay so the topic of this video are
atoms and molecules in the periodic
table so let's go ahead and get
started okay so what is an atom well
it's the basic unit of matter and atoms
really have three main parts three
subatomic parts and two of those parts
are in What's called the nucleus first
of all there are the protons protons
have a positive charge and in this case
I'm going to label three protons with a
A plus symbol because they have a
positive charge also in the nucleus are
the neutrons neutrons have no charge
they're neutral and in this case I'm
going to make 1 2 3 four neutrons and so
notice how they're all clumped around
one another this is known as the nucleus
of the atom and then there's What's
called the electron cloud electrons
orbit kind of like planets around the
Sun electrons which have which are the
third part have a negative charge and
they orbit in these levels around the
nucleus and what one thing I want you to
see is that usually the protons and
electrons will be in the same amount of
numbers so there's three electrons and
you can see there's one 2 three protons
this is a basic model of what an atom
might look
like so here we have the diagram called
the periodic table of elements and what
an element is it's a substance made from
only one kind of atom and this table
here keeps track of all the elements
that are known to exist you probably
heard of some of these gold Au is the
symbol for gold this nugget of gold
right here is made from trillions and
trillions of atoms but they're all atoms
of the same element
gold this sheet of aluminum foil Al is
aluminum this sheet is made from
trillions and trillions of atoms but
they're all atoms of the same element
aluminum but some man-made items are
actually created from a mixture of
elements for example when you mix iron
and carbon together they make steel so
steel like these steel cables for
construction or steel like this
stainless steel serving dish right here
we can combine elements to make other
materials so let's go over the basics on
how you read the periodic table let's
zoom into the square for carbon and
there's a six and a 12
the smaller number six this is always
the atomic number and by definition this
tells me the number of protons that an
atom has so I now know Carbon has six
protons and then that usually is going
to tell me the number of electrons as
well so six protons and six
electrons now here's an analogy see this
man right here if you were to weigh
himself before getting a haircut and
after getting a haircut would there
really be any noticeable difference on
his scale I hope you see the answer is
no there's not going to going to be much
obvious difference because the mass of
this man's hair is just so tiny and
insignificant compared to the rest of
his body well what's my point well look
at the 12 the 12 is called the atomic
mass it's basically the mass of the of
the atom and you obtain the mass by
adding up the protons and the neutrons
well how come we don't include the
electrons because the electrons kind of
like the man's hair from a moment ago
are so small and insignificant they're
just too small to affect the mass so we
only add up the protons and the neutrons
so if we try to figure out how many
protons electrons and neutrons does
carbon have or the six on top tells me
six protons six protons usually means
six electrons now the 12 tells me when I
add up the protons and neutrons I'll
come to 12 so six protons plus what
mystery number brings me to 12 that
would also be six is the number going to
be the same three numbers all the time
let's do another one
here's the element
burum I hope you see burum would have
four protons because it has four protons
four electrons now the mass is nine so
four protons plus what mystery number of
neutrons brings me to nine that would be
five so here's another set of practice
problems go ahead and pause the video
I'm going to go over the answers in 3 2
one so based on the periodic table
Square the atomic mass of
chlorine is 35 amus atomic mass units
Part B what is the atomic number of
chlorine well that's the smaller of the
numbers that's the
17 part C how many electrons does
chlorine contain well I know it's got 17
protons and the protons and electrons
are usually the same Part D how many
protons that's the number 17 on top
that's the definition of the atomic
number 17 and how many neutrons well I
know the mass is 35 and I know there's
17 protons plus what mystery number of
neutrons brings me to 35 that would be
18 so here are some practice problems
pause the video I'm going to go over the
answers in 3 2 1 so question a what's
the atomic mass well the atomic mass is
the larger of the two numbers that's the
35 the atomic number that's the smaller
of the two numbers that's the
17 question C how many electrons does
chlorine have well I can usually figure
that out from the atomic number which is
the number of protons 17 protons means
17 electrons question D how many protons
that's the definition of the atomic
number that's the definition of the 17
and for question e how many neutrons
well the mass is 35 17 prot
plus what mystery number brings me to 35
Hope you said
18 so let's talk about the electron
cloud and electrons as said earlier
electrons will orbit the nucleus in
levels let's talk about the first level
the first level is the level closest to
the nucleus let me add a dotted Circle
to represent it now the first level can
only carry up to two electrons it's
stable with one two electrons now these
electrons are in motion and the goal of
an atom is to have its electron levels
filled or to become stable now this
would be a model of what helium might
look like helium only has two electrons
so helium is already a stable atom but a
lot of atoms have more than two
electrons so they might have a second
electron level let me go ahead and add a
second electron level and they're a
second dotted line now the second
electron level can only carry up to
eight electrons
and so let's add eight electrons 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 if the second electron level has
eight electrons it would also be
considered filled and stable and this is
the electrons are in motion this is by
the way what what neon and E might look
like both the first and second level are
filled but most atoms aren't like that
and there's even atoms that might even
have more than 10 electrons and they
might have to have a third electron
level so let me add a third circle now
the third level like the second can
carry eight electrons 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
eight and if there are eight in the
third level it would be considered
filled and stable those electrons are
also in motion and this is what argon
might look like 18 electrons two in
level one eight in level two eight in
level three that makes 18 atoms are
stable whenever their outermost level is
filled and their outermost level is
known as the veence level if you've
heard the word veence before that refers
to whatever level is the outside level
that's the veilance level atoms are
trying to obtain uh their veilance level
to become filled and
stable let's pause and try to answer
this question two of these three atoms
are not stable pause the video I'm going
to show the answers in 3 2 1 Adam a is
unstable it only has six electrons in
its second level it needs eight atom B
is unstable it only has seven electrons
in its second level it needs eight atom
C is stable because it has eight
electrons so what would atoms like atom
a and atom B what would atoms do when
they're unstable well pretend we have
these two blue hydrogen atoms that are
unstable and this one green oxygen atom
that's unstable when atoms are unstable
they bond with each other to become a
molecule water for example is made from
three atoms two unstable hydrogens and
one unstable oxygen but when they bond
they actually become stable and they
make a molecule let's talk about
that so let's talk about molecules now
molecules are two or more atoms that are
held together by a chemical bond and
they form because the atoms that are
involved are unstable stable their
electron levels are not filled now you
may have heard of the two kinds of of
bonds first we're going to talk about
calent bonds and this is a chemical bond
where the atoms that are involved will
share electrons between one another
great example of this is the atmospheric
oxygen that we breathe O2 it's made from
two atoms one two of oxygen one in green
one in red now oxygen here's the Square
from the periodic table has eight
protons which means eight electrons I'm
going to draw the eight electrons first
in the green oxygen one two electrons in
level one level one stable but now
there's only 1 2 3 4 five six electrons
in level two I hope you see oxygen on
the left and green is unstable let's do
the same thing in the red one one two in
level one level one stable one 2 3 4 5 6
oxygen and red Just Like Oxygen and
green is unstable both of these atoms
are
unstable so in order to become stable
really they just overlap their electrons
and those four that are in the middle
are going to be shared between them
let's see
that notice how the four shared
electrons go back and forth between both
of the oxygens now in reality all the
other electrons are in motion as well
the other electrons are just not being
shared I just animated these just to
draw your attention into the ones that
are being shared so these two atoms are
sharing the four electrons that you see
in motion combined with the four that
they're not sharing the green one
becomes stable combined with the four
that they're not sharing the red one
becomes stable this is a calent
bond so next let's talk about an ionic
bond and this is a chemical bond where
electrons are gained by one atom but
lost by another and the cause of this is
a theft one atom is actually going to
steal at least one electron from another
atom good example of this is sodium na
is sodium it normally has 11 positive
protons it normally has 11 negative
electrons so its charge is normally zero
the 11 positives are canceled out by the
11 negatives but in an ionic bond
another atom actually comes and steals
one of its 11 electrons leaving it with
only 10 and by doing so the charge is
now uh different it's not zero anymore
it now has a charge of plus one because
it has more protons sodium would now fit
the definition of an ion in this case it
would be an atom with a positive charge
now sodium actually benefits from the
theft because now it only has 10
electrons if I draw the 10 electrons I
could put two electrons in level one and
eight electrons three 4 5 6 7 eight
electrons in level two notice how both
levels are stable prior to this theft
sodium would have had an 11th electron
one electron in the third level and it
would not have been stable let's go
ahead and explore how this works in more
detail let's look at a pretty common
example of an ionic bond involving
sodium in red and chlorine in blue we're
going to fill in the before and the
after table before they bond on the left
and after they bond on the right now
sodium normally has 11 positive protons
which means 11 negative electrons let me
draw the 11 electrons one two electrons
in level one that's stable 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
eight electrons in level two that's
stable but one electron in level three
sodium right now is unstable now look at
the charge of sodium 11 positives 11
negatives the net overall charge zero
now let's look at chlorine chlorine
normally has 17 positive protons which
means 17 negative electrons let me draw
the 17 electrons 1 2 in level one it's
stable 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 eight electrons in
level two level two is stable but now
there's seven left over 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
chlorine third level is not filled you
need eight electrons to fill level three
it only has seven but look at chlorine
charge 17 positives 17 negatives its net
overall charge is
zero so right now sodium and chlorine
are just two unstable atoms how do they
actually make an ionic bond well what
we're going to see chlorine is going to
steal chlorine is going to be the thief
it's going to steal that red electron
there it goes by stealing that red
electron they all be they both become
stable and they're going to bond with
one another in red let's look at sodium
first its first level was always stable
the second level was always stable it
doesn't even have a third level anymore
we can erase it in blue chlorine first
level was stable the second level was
stable the third level is now stable
because it just filled it from the by by
stealing the red
electron now the proton numbers never
change this is a big mistake sometimes
students make sodium
and Chlor chlorine their proton Numbers
Never Change it's the electron that was
taken sodium lost an electron it only
has 10 now and that's why sodium ends up
with a positive charge chlorine used to
have 17 electrons but it stole one more
to make 18 that's why chlorine has a
negative charge you have more electrons
your charge is going to be negative
sodium in red is a positively charged
ion chlorine green and blue is a
negatively charged ion and that's why
they bond they're held together by their
opposing charges opposite charges
attract sodium and chloride uh chlorine
makes sodium chloride better known as
salt so this is one of the most common
examples you're going to see of an ionic
bond just because of how common and
familiar we are with salt great example
of an ionic
bond so here's a little practice quiz go
ahead and try this if you're in my class
pause the video and happy I'm happy to
check your answers before class or after
class one day thanks for watching